last London system
correctly yeah something something like
that and yeah Magnus at some point I
think uh decided to go for some very
risky stuff which
uh you know maybe would have scared some
lesser players into compliance and you
know an attempt to equalize but you know
Richard is really nothing of the sort
and he I think very gratefully accepted
accepted the challenge and uh ended up
out calculating and Out playing minus in
that game uh he's also not having you
know the best tournament uh ever it
feels but you know playing solidly
nothing much wrong being done
and uh where do you predict the
excitement will lie today uh I guess in
a lot of the games but where do you
predict most of the action maybe some of
the blood will be I'm slightly cheating
here because some moves are coming in
and it's uh it's obviously a lot easier
to predict when you uh when you see the
opening moves and so far you know I kind
of like the one which still has the
starting position